I have never been more excited in my
entire life to do an unboxing video I
want to say this right up front
follow geared towards Inc on Instagram
right away because after I unbox what's
in here and I made sure I have not seen
the actual design of this give you guys
a little history okay gear towards Inc
would hit us up on our live streams
every once in a while hit me up on
Instagram we got to talking basically he
said he makes some customized shoes and
here are some photos to give you an
example
aren't these freaking awesome aren't
they beautiful he's saying he can
customize anything and I was like
anything DJ can you really so I gave him
a suggestion I said can you do this for
me and he's like I'll get on it a week
and a half later all the way from the
beautiful state of Tennessee to
California I got this box of shoes right
here so excited to see what you asked
probably in the thumbnail already but I
have not seen a picture of it I have no
idea what it's actually gonna look like
but this is probably in the thumbnail
here's what I said I say can you do one
shoe where it's a face of Heath Ledger's
Joker and the other shoe a face of
Arthur flex cherry let's see what's in
stores doing a drumroll and I
specifically want to John here to be
jealous I'm gonna buy yeah my bad cop
routine oh I'm gonna try not to look at
this Dilla box in this boy oh oh there
ban all people my hands he bought these
in a stupid okay this is perfect cuz I
don't have to actually look into guys
I'm not actually looking I'm just gonna
grab that lid though okay okay a minor
upgrade to your shoe collection oh oh
there's a little letter D cuz customized
letter for me Greg I hope get away from
I'm sure this I'll more show the lid the
lids got stuff on oh my god we'll take a
photo all right
Gregg John you're here to be jealous not
much so jealous that's why this is I
want to touch it
deal I'm trying to teach you how to be a
real friend Gregg enjoy out of last make
and then you're giving me many years of
laughs and entertainment I have always
imagined my life going when summer to
not fall into the system for you to open
this and show the world really means a
lot
shoes have been sprayed oh ho so you're
all set and if John is there hello John
hi
your shoes are next if you want some oh
here we go Greg helping out John again
that's right yeah so put on a happy face
choker and remember that's live Johnny
doesn't he looks like Johnny Depp in his
thumbnail DJ crowds already like against
you want to get to the shoes you know DJ
JD would you please stop I'm trying to
I'm trying to get to the gun jealous you
just it's just so damn jealous that's it
so jealous right ruining the times okay
shoe number one Joker calling card in
here oh that's awesome put it in a
plastic bag submitted to ever oh my god
look at that look how gorgeous that is
dude that is perfect and signed by him
too oh my god DJ this is amazing I'm 50%
jealous Oh get ready to get a hundred
fifty percent jealous three shoes oh
here comes my mother always told me to
smile put on a happy shoot
[Music]
these are pretty freakin sick oh my god
guys look at this look at that
oh dude you both have to wear these
everywhere but also never wear these oh
my god so awesome EJ you've outdone
yourself all right I'm gonna roll this
video of DJ saying what you can do if
you want to get yourself some custom
shoes from the guy obviously they're
worth it look at look at this they're
obviously worth it
no no BS here I'm gonna roll that video
and while that video is playing I'm
gonna put on these shoes what's up guys
it's geared towards ink so if you want
shoes like use a saw Greg opening you
can DM me on Instagram I can do any
design you want on slip-on vans wide
airforces black airforces timberlands
Doc Martens whatever you want I can do
any design you want it can be any artist
that you like or any musician you like
or an actor whoever the hell it is I can
do it just do me on Instagram there's no
better way to spend quarantine than
getting some customized shoes i'm greg
thank you for featuring me in your video
bro hope you really like the shoes as
much as I like to doing them give me on
Instagram be safe out there and stay
clean yeah
Oh buddy how do I look you look like a
joke shoe tastic or not yeah oh my god
it's so great - this is so awesome oh my
god I'm gonna get so much attention
everywhere I go and that's what life is
all about I clearly look like someone
who likes Batman what was your first
guess DJ I've been overwhelmingly
grateful though all the conversations
we've been having have just been
incredibly endearing you're such a sweet
human being
I hope Tristan is giving you some
awesome pleasure right now Tristan is
his girlfriend
just to clarify and while you guys are
quarantined I hope you guys alternate
between your shoes keep them on some
women don't like that when you keep the
shoes on in the bedroom oh but I'm sure
with you she's like put those posts
Malone and Eminem shoes as you like do a
rotation
of shoes every 10 minutes just to get
all our favorite there's a link in the
description box message him personally
if you want to get some shoes seriously
these are absolutely worth it and
they're very freakin comfortable I mean
come on thank you guys so much and thank
you DJ geared towards Inc specifically